déconstruire un ouvrage de l'envergure
de l'ancien penchant plein a représenté
tout un défi il fallait réaliser
l'opération de la façon la plus
sécuritaire possible tout en préservant
le fleuve et sa faune
il a été l'objet de fierté puis
d'inquiétude
Texas
pendant des décennies le pont Champlain
a été le pont le plus emprunté au Canada
son immense structure d'acier était une
icône dans le paysage de Montréal je me
souviens
son histoire c'est terminé prématurément
sa structure n'a pas résisté aux hivers
québécois
elle menaçait de s'effondrer le vieux
pont Champlain était malade ça faisait
des années qu'il fallait le déconstruire
sans remplaçant le pont Samuel de
Champlain a déjà pris la relève
pour faire disparaître l'ancienne
structure les ingénieurs et les
travailleurs doivent relever deux grands
défis
le premier c'est d'éviter que la
structure ne s'effondre pendant son
démantèlement c'est vraiment une
déconstruction c'est pas une démolition
donc pour faire un parallèle c'est comme
le jeu de Mikado faut tirer les bons
bâtons dans le bon ordre pour s'assurer
que la structure s'écroule pas le vieux
penchant plein c'est 200000 tonnes de
béton 25000 tonnes d'acier
les travailleurs vont retirer les pièces
une à une
[Musique]
banlieue de New York pour faire
disparaître le vieux pont tapenzie en
2019 on ne s'est pas donné autant de mal
les exposés ont fait sauter une grande
partie de l'ouvrage similaire au pont
Champlain directement dans le fleuve
Hudson vous imaginez ramasser tout le
béton qui tombe dans le fleuve avec tout
ce que ça génère comme comment en jeu
comme risque et puis comme dégâts au
niveau de l'environnement
protéger l'environnement c'est le
deuxième défi les abords du pont
Champlain sont le lieu de refuge de
dizaines d'espèces de poissons et
d'oiseaux dont certaines sont
vulnérables
les graisses les peintures ou le plomb
qu'on trouve dans les pièces du pont
pourraient les contaminer s'il tombe
dans le fleuve le fleuve Saint-Laurent
on l'a beaucoup perturbé dans le passé
donc c'est important aussi qu'on modifie
nos façons de faire qu'on mette en place
les mesures les plus innovantes les plus
respectueuses de l'environnement la
société d'État fédérales Ponge à
quartier et Champlain incorporé ou PJ
CCI et le maître d'oeuvre du projet
elle a confié les travaux au consortium
nouvelle horizon Saint-Laurent ou NHL
former des films d'ingénierie Pomerlo et
delcent Ayem c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on fait ce genre de projet là c'est
aussi emblématique parce que c'est un
pont qui a eu une histoire et puis on
vient effacer cette histoire là
[Musique]
c'est en 1957 que débute la construction
du pont Champlain
doit s'étirer au-dessus du fleuve
Saint-Laurent de l'île des sœurs jusqu'à
Brossard sur 3,4 km
tous les 50 mètres on coule d'immenses
semelles en béton au fond du fleuve
elle soutiennent des piliers qu'on
appelle des piles
et par dessus de grosses poutres
transversales en béton armé les chevaux
pour construire le tablier la partie sur
laquelle roule les voitures on dépose
sur les chevets 7 poutres longitudinale
ces poutres sont faites de béton
précontraints qu'on juge plus économique
que la scie
entre l'île des sœurs et la voie
maritime le pont compte 40 Travis
d'approche
du côté de Brossard il y en a 9
pour enjamber la voie maritime au
circule les navires il faut adopter une
stratégie différente
on ne peut pas placer des semelles et
des piles dans l'eau
de chaque côté du chenal on est riche
une immense structure d'acier en
porte-à-faux
à travers principal au-dessus de la voie
maritime et suspendu entre les deux
le pont est ouvert à la circulation le
29 juin 1962
la nouvelle structure va rapidement
dévoiler ses failles
en hiver les selles de déclaçage
attaquent les poutres de béton
précontraint
dès 1986 il faut renforcer la structure
avec des câbles et plus tard avec des
arbalètes et des treillis
mais ces efforts ne seront pas
suffisants en 2019 le pont Champlain est
fermé définitivement
les travailleurs d'autrefois ont mis 5
ans pour construire le pont
ce d'aujourd'hui vont en mettre trois
pour le faire disparaître
l'ingénieur Antoine audoino dirige le
projet il y a toute une séquence en
respecter on fait le film à l'envers
quoi si on veut
[Musique]
la première étape c'est d'enlever les
treillis en acier qu'on avait installé
en renfort sous les poutres endommagées
du début jusqu'à la fin c'est une
opération quand même délicate
une barge est arrivée entre deux piles
sous une travée
à partir de cette plateforme flottante
deux travailleurs s'élèvent dans des
nacelles pour rejoindre les extrémités
du treillis donc on vient enlever toute
l'attention dans l'élément il devient un
peu plus un peu plus ou moins lâche on
va dire mais il est toujours suspendu
par ses supports
il faut maintenant attacher chaque
extrémité du treillis à l'une des grues
qui se trouve sur le tablier
dernier moment on coupe les suspentes
pour libérer la pièce
elle pèse 50 tonnes on appelle ça un
levage en tandem le treillis est
descendu de manière équilibrée les deux
grutiers communiquent il y a un chef de
manœuvre sur la barge qui coordonne
toute la manœuvre comme un chef
d'orchestre et puis qui permet aux
treillis descendre doucement puis
s'asseoir sur la barge
[Musique]
on amène le treillis jusqu'au quai pour
le démanteler
celui-ci s'en va se faire découper puis
traiter puis il va te transformer soit
en acier des véhicules ou tout un tas de
choses qu'on peut faire avec de l'acier
chaque fois qu'on enlève un treillis la
structure devient un peu plus fragile
les ingénieurs ont tout calculé il y a
certaines travées qui sont plus
endommagés que d'autres donc à ce moment
là il y a une séquence particulière avec
le positionnement des grues mais aussi
avec les accès les camions qui viennent
sur le tablier du pont pour récupérer
certaines pièces peuvent pas circuler
dans n'importe quelle voie et puis on a
aussi des séquences particulières dans
l'enlèvement des treillis
au même moment en bordure de l'île des
sœurs on commence à déconstruire le
tablier du pont
[Musique]
si l'eau n'est pas assez profonde pour
utiliser des barges
on a ménagé une immense jetée temporaire
pour travailler à sec
120 000 tonnes de roches ont été
déversés dans le fleuve
l'ingénieur Philippe Larouche est chargé
d'environnement chez pjcci
il doit s'assurer que l'aménagement des
jetés n'aura pas d'impact sur la qualité
de l'eau
pour réaliser la jetée on les a
dimensionne en fonction de la vitesse
d'écoulement en fonction des vagues des
glaces donc pour éviter justement qu'il
y ait l'érosion puis qui est des
matières suspension qui descendent dans
le fleuve
la jeté de l'île des sœurs se trouve sur
la route migratoire de plusieurs espèces
de poissons dont la chigans et
l'esturgeon jaune
pour éviter de bloquer leur passage
l'océanographe Stéphane Lorrain a conçu
du couloir migratoire qui traverse la
jetée
vont monter pour aller chercher des
substrats adéquats à la menthe certaines
espèces peuvent monter jusqu'au rapide
de la Chine
de la chigans principalement pour
vérifier si ça fonctionne on a installé
des électrodes de part et d'autre du
couloir
le passage de poisson déclenche un
signal dont l'amplitude et
proportionnelle à la taille de
l'individu
35 cm des caméras sous-marines captent
les poissons sur le vif pour permettre
aux biologiste de confirmer l'espèce
nettement que tu es en fin de journée il
y a beaucoup de poissons
par jour de l'ordre de centaines de
poissons donc ça fonctionne très bien
on va aller à la 35 qu'on va se laisser
dériver il n'y a pas que sous l'eau
qu'on guette les animaux dans les airs
aussi voilà un petit peu plus loin
Stéphane s'il te plaît la conseillère en
environnement Catherine Julien tente de
repérer les hirondelles à front blanc
une espèce dont la situation est
précaire
elle observe la structure du pont à la
recherche de nid on en a un là-bas si
elle trouve une actif les travaux de
démolition devront s'arrêter
la front-blanc avaient l'habitude de
nicher sous le vieux pont Champlain
pour les inciter à construire leur nid
ailleurs ce printemps on a installé des
filets sous le tablier
mais quelques couples ont élu domicile
sur les bordures du pont puis je vais
avoir du va-et-vient
cette section ne pourra pas être
démantelée tant que oisillons n'auront
pas quitté le
nids
ailleurs on vient modifier le phasage
des travaux pour ne pas effectuer leur
période de multiplication
entre la jetée de l'île des soeurs et la
Voie maritime du Saint-Laurent 30
travées vont être déconstruites à partir
de l'eau
pour s'attaquer à cette tâche risquez et
complexe l'équipe de NHL s'affaire à
construire une barge catamaran baptisée
le géant du fleuve c'est deux patinoires
de hockey de la NH c'est un assemblage
de deux barges de fleurs des gros BIM
d'acier pour connecter tout ça
un système de levage est installé à bord
il est formé de cesto rouge
elles peuvent atteindre la hauteur d'un
édifice de 9 étages et soulevé jusqu'à
4800 tonnes
elles devront lever les través du pont
d'un seul bloc au-dessus de l'eau sans
faire chavirer la barre
quelques mois plus tard la barge
catamaran est en pleine action ça a été
un peu compliqué à démarrer en termes de
préparation mais ça c'est normal c'est
un ouvrage un peu exceptionnel tout de
suite au bout de deux travées on a
réussi à atteindre notre cycle de
travail prévu
le géant du fleuve est positionné sous
une travée
durant toute l'opération il va devoir
rester parfaitement horizontal ça se
déplace en x et en y dont deux
directions la barge elle a aussi une
gîte et une assiette donc tout ça est
contrôlé par GPS et puis avec des
inclinomètre des lasers pour permettre
de garantir la stabilité de tout le
système dans toute l'opération du
démantèlement
[Musique]
à la même vitesse
une fois les tours appuyez sur le
tablier il faut faire décoller la travée
de ses appuis et on va déballer la barge
la barre j'ai rempli de 2000 tonnes
d'eau pour la caler et là on vient vider
de l'eau c'est la poussée d'Archimède
donc là ça se lève ça se lève et puis on
vient prendre une grande partie du poids
de la travée
dans la salle de contrôle l'équipe est
aux aguets
pour éviter que la barge ne se renverse
on vérifie si les charges soutenues par
les tours correspondent à ce qui avait
été calculé chaque trajet est différente
en fait géométriquement c'est la même
elles sont toutes faites pareil avec
cette peau de précontrain tout en béton
même dimension mais il y a eu des
réparations au fil du temps c'est
réparations modifié le poids des travées
jusqu'à une centaine de tonnes environ
une fois que la travée repose
entièrement sur les tours la barge
catamaran 5500 tonnes
il faut la tirer contre le courant
jusqu'en amont du pont l'idée
effectivement c'est d'amener la travée
pas trop loin de sa position de
démantèlement pour éviter d'avoir un
naviguer avec quelque chose de très
lourd sur le fleuve qui est risqué
quelques mètres du pont la barge et sa
lourde cargaison s'arrête
[Musique]
on démolit la travée directement sur le
fleuve
le béton sera transporté sur des petites
barges jusqu'au quai
la travée a disparu
une autre tranche du passé vient d'être
effacée
[Musique]
1er décembre 2021
sur le chantier de déconstruction du
pont Champlain on prépare la descente de
la travée principale qui surplombe la
voie maritime
[Musique]
cette section centrale de la structure
métallique emblématique du pont doit
descendre d'un seul bloc suspendu au
bout de 6 câbles
enlevez la trappe principale ne devrait
pas mettre en péril la stabilité du
reste de la structure métallique
de part et d'autre de la voie maritime
les deux structures emportent à faux
sont autoportantes
la travée principale est suspendue entre
les deux
[Musique]
sur le tablier du pont on sait faire à
installer de gigantesques bobines et les
verrai à câble qui vont faire le travail
et c'est 6 vérins synchronisés ensemble
vont descendre la travée une fois qu'on
aura découpé et de solidariser la travée
suspendue du reste de la structure et
puis on va descendre la structure
entièrement sur une barge à l'intérieur
du chenal de la voie maritime
pour éviter que la structure ne se brise
une fois déposée sur la barge on ajoute
des renforcements à des endroits
stratégiques une fois qu'elle est assise
sur la barge les points d'appui changent
elle est plus suspendue donc la travée
est plus en effet de flexion comme ça
mais dans le sens inverse avec des
points d'appui qui sont différents donc
là les efforts transférés dans les
membres sont différents donc on a
rajouté de l'acier temporaire sur la
structure
les équipes travaillent 7 jours sur 7
pour préparer la descente
l'opération est prévue pour le début
janvier quand la voie maritime sera
fermée à la circulation des navets
faut pas attendre trop longtemps dans la
fermeture qui est de début janvier afin
mars parce que plus on attend plus les
conditions hivernales vont être
difficiles plus la glace va se former
dans le chenal plus ça va être compliqué
de manipuler la barge à l'intérieur du
chenal
Tom le 6 janvier en pleine nuit
il fait moins 7 degrés Celsius
des monteurs d'acier s'accrochent à la
structure métallique du vieux pont
Champlain
il s'allume leur torche
c'est à 23 heures que le feu d'artifice
commence
[Musique]
les travailleurs découpent les poutres
d'acier pour libérer la structure
[Musique]
prennent en charge le poids de la travée
principale ils sont gardés bien au chaud
sous des abris une température
inférieure à 10 degré Celsius pourrait
enrayer leur mécanique
le découpage passe prolonger tout au
long de la nuit
[Musique]
à 10 heures du matin c'est le moment
attendu
[Musique]
la descente peut enfin commencer
à travers principal se détache tu restes
de la structure
[Musique]
2200 tonnes d'acier 60 ans d'histoire
suspendus dans le ciel
non ne pas nerveux parce que l'opération
était planifiée depuis très longtemps
l'ensemble des risques ont été évalués
et tous les mesures ont été mis en place
pour s'assurer que l'opération se passe
correctement il y a toujours des points
critiques que tu as un petit doute parce
que tu planifies tu le mets sur le
papier tu veux que ça se passe tel que
tu l'avais prévu et pour l'instant on
frappe tous les marques qu'on avait
dansé
[Musique]
Simon et Bert et directeur adjoint du
projet de déconstruction
comme le reste de son équipe il a peu
dormi au cours des derniers jours c'est
le point culminant du projet il y a plus
de 18 mois de travail qui est en arrière
de cette opération là
dans les câbles et étroitement
surveillés
il ne faut pas que la travée soit des
balancée ni dans le sens de la longueur
ni dans le sens de la largeur
elle descend de 40 cm à la fois
à une vitesse moyenne de 3 à 5 mètres à
l'heure il faut qu'on fasse des
ajustements mais ça se passe très bien
on contrôle la charge exactement comme
on le veut la descente est d'abord
censée durer de 6 à 8 heures
mais le froid et la neige compliquent
les opérations c'est pas un ascenseur ça
aurait été une femme que ça soit
instantanée mais pour un c'est les
équipements qui sont très très précis on
travaille au millimètre près et puisque
c'est des charges qui sont énormes mais
on se doit d'y aller tranquillement
l'atterrissage est initialement prévu
pour 17h
[Musique]
à travers touchera finalement la barge à
trois heures du matin
[Musique]
8 janvier c'est le jour 3 de l'opération
ce matin le froid est glacial
des remorqueurs placés de part et
d'autre de la barge la font pivoter
[Musique]
à 17h le convoi s'est bronze
les remorqueurs fondent les glaces
chargées de leur étrange colis
[Musique]
à travers
elle va hiberner quelques kilomètres en
amont
[Musique]
c'est au premier jour du printemps qu'on
commence à la démonter
certaines pièces serviront à des fins de
recherche
d'autres seront réutilisés
mais la grande majorité sera recyclée
[Musique]
d'acier dans un rayon de 150 km donc ça
c'est une mesure qui évite que la scie
soit mis dans des containers et chipé à
l'étranger pour être recyclé à
l'étranger pour ensuite nous être
revendu
tous les camions qui transportent les
matériaux sont pesés à leur sortie du
chantier
ce qu'on peut voir les camions oui ils
seront suivis par GPS et peser à nouveau
à leur point d'arrivée
donc ça nous permet de pouvoir s'assurer
qu'il y a pas de disposition non
conforme illégale on s'assure que il va
à l'endroit qu'il est prévu
prend le chemin d'une fonderie
le béton lui est envoyé par un centre de
valorisation
il sera concassé et réutilisé dans des
chaussées
[Applaudissements]
de part et d'autre de la Voie maritime
du Saint-Laurent les deux structures
d'acier ont porte à faux sont toujours
debout
[Musique]
on commence à découper celle du côté de
Brossard
[Musique]
une grue retire les pièces une à une
chaque fois qu'on enlève une poutre on
joue sur l'équilibre de la structure
pour éviter les fondrement on a boulonné
des renforcements à des endroits
stratégiques
[Musique]
on a aussi placé des tours temporaires
sous la structure le plus grand défi
qu'on vit actuellement c'est toujours
travailler avec ce que nous on appelle
l'existence c'est-à-dire que c'est une
structure qui est bon c'est une vieille
structure qui existe depuis longtemps on
travaille sur la base des informations
qu'on a il y a toujours des inconnus
[Musique]
en principe on connaît le gabarit de
chaque pièce
mais les plans d'origine ont été faits à
la main dans les années 1950
ils utilisent des modèles numériques
élaborés à l'aide de drone
c'est l'étape 5 mais cette technologie a
ses limites il faut procéder avec
extrême prudence
partout sur la structure on a installé
des capteurs
ça vérifie le comportement de l'acier
c'est des déplacements et puis s'il y a
des tensions qui étaient pas prévues au
niveau de certaines members principales
qui pourraient être des indicateurs que
la structure est en stress et qu'on se
dirigerait vers une catastrophe
potentielle
en moyenne on enlève 8 à 12 pièces par
jour
mais elle va bientôt falloir suspendre
cette partie des travaux
la jetée sur laquelle se trouve la grue
va devoir être démantelée pour laisser
passer les bateaux de plaisance durant
l'été
[Musique]
il faudra attendre l'automne 2022 pour
finir de démanteler la première
structure en porte-à-faux
[Musique]
19 mai 2022
entre l'île des sœurs et la Voie
maritime du Saint-Laurent les 30 travées
au-dessus de l'eau ont été retirées
le géant du fleuve a terminé son travail
il reste à déconstruire les piles et les
semelles qui se trouvent au fond du
fleuve
ici on s'attaque à une pile
pour éviter que des morceaux de pétons
ne tombent dans l'eau on a ceinturé la
pile avec des barges des plateaux
d'acier et une membrane de caoutchouc
épisode ça permet de créer une zone
complètement étanche au pied du fût de
la pile les pelles de démolition donc
démolisse le chevet et puis ensuite le
sucre
la mauvaise qualité du béton utilisée
pour construire le pont Champlain dans
les années 1950 à donner du fil à
retordre aux ingénieurs pendant la vie
utile du pont cette fois elle accélère
le travail
à certains endroits le béton est très
friable donc c'est très probablement
très peu de poudre de ciment beaucoup de
sable et d'eau et granulats ce qui fait
en sorte que il y a certaines piles qui
se déconstruisent plus vite que d'autres
quelques mètres plus loin on s'affaire à
déconstruire une semelle c'est la
dernière étape des travaux maritimes
les semelles de béton qui soutenaient
les piles du pont au fond du fleuve sont
immenses
elles font 10 mètres de largeur
des excavatrices les cases sous la
surface de l'eau l'opérateur travaille à
l'aveugle il y a des profondeurs d'eau
qui varient entre 3 à 7 8 mètres de
profondeur et pour ce faire il utilise
un équipement GPS
avant de débuter la démolition on a
utilisé des sonars pour cartographier
l'emplacement de chaque semelle
l'information est communiquée à
l'opérateur de l'excavatrice
le bras de s'appelle avec son marteau à
quel endroit il casse à quelle
profondeur il faut qu'il se rende
pour empêcher le béton de partir à la
dérive on a cloisonné la zone de travail
avec des parois d'acier qui descendent
jusqu'au fond de l'eau
des morceaux de béton sont transférés
sur des barges et évacuées jusqu'au quai
chaque semelle est déconstruite jusqu'à
un demi mètre sous le lit du fleuve
et puis ce trou entre guillemets qu'on a
constitué avec la démolition vient la
remplir de grosses roches de la pierre
nette pour reconstituer un peu l'habitat
naturel du poisson
[Musique]
à l'automne 2022 les travaux maritimes
sont pratiquement terminés
[Musique]
NHL ou encore des construire l'une des
structures en porte-à-faux en bordure de
la voie maritime
et démolir les quatre cravés du pont qui
passent au dessus de la route 132 sur la
Rive-Sud du fleuve
le 5 novembre le samedi matin 22 pelles
mécaniques sont mobilisées
il faut faire vite
on a fermé la route 132 à 22 heures
vendredi soir
c'est un lien névralgique pour la
mobilité autour de Montréal
impossible de la garder fermée au-delà
du weekend
donc là la fin de semaine là c'est
environ 12000 tonnes de béton démoli en
à peu près 20 heures donc la fin de
semaine c'est 50 heures au total il y a
de la préparation avant de la démolition
puis du ramassage à la fin nettoyage
pour pouvoir réouvrir
80 travailleurs se relaient 24 heures
sur 24
et faite de cette poutres longitudinale
on devait les démolir une par une mais
on a changé de stratégie pour aller plus
vite
les trois poutres centrales vont tomber
d'un seul bloc on vient faire une
méthode hybride on va dire donc on vient
déconstruire des pots de soi
mécaniquement entière une par une comme
ce que vous voyez derrière en ce moment
ou alors pour la partie centrale on va
venir faire ce qu'on appelle des drops
donc des chutes contrôlées
[Musique]
les ingénieurs ont utilisé des modèles
numériques pour identifier exactement où
l'appel doit cogner pour affaiblir les
poutres et les faire tomber sous leur
propre poids
ils ont calculé de quelle façon chaque
poutre à l'aise briser combien de
morceaux et même sur quelle distance les
morceaux de béton allaient être
propulsés
par travée pour éviter les effets
dominos donc il y a une séquence
particulière
ça y est trois poutres sont sur le point
de céder
durant la nuit de vendredi à samedi les
travailleurs ont installé 15000 tonnes
de pierre sur la route pour absorber les
chats
des tas de pierre servent à protéger les
infrastructures souterraines
stratégiques comme la queueduque de la
Ville de Brossard donc la prout pèse
environ 200 tonnes sauf quand elle chute
avec sa hauteur elle génère jusqu'à 4000
tonnes d'impact donc c'est cette
charge-là qu'il faut essayer de
d'absorber pour pour assurer l'intégrité
des ouvrages existants
la démolition au dessus de la route 132
sera le dernier défi relevé par l'équipe
d'Antoine oduano
de la rive sud du fleuve la vue sur
Montréal est transformée
les ingénieurs les scientifiques et les
travailleurs ont gagné leur pari
ils ont fait disparaître 200000 tonnes
de béton et 25000 tonnes d'acier en
limitant les impacts sur le fleuve
je peux pas dire que tout ce qu'on a
réalisé très bien fonctionné mais il y a
beaucoup de choses qu'on a essayé puis
qui vont justement leur montrer la barre
un certain niveau
[Musique]
très bientôt il ne restera que des
vestiges du vieux pont Champlain
on vient fermer le dernier chapitre je
dirais
les gens qu'on travaillait dessus à la
réparer à le renforcer déjà pour eux
c'est un peu spécial de défaire ce
qu'ils ont fait donc c'est un peu
particulier mais ça fait partie de la
vie quoi c'est intéressant aussi de voir
le cycle l'évolution complète d'un
ouvrage dans ces dernières années et
puis venir fermer la boucle
quelques piliers choisi pour rester
debout symboliseront le passé
[Musique]
il témoigneront de l'expertise de ceux
et celles qui ont bâti puis déconstruits